[Music]
what is up everybody it's adam ak here
for anime uproar and in this video i
will be talking about the absolutely
insane recent developments in the seven
deadly sins story and to be honest i am
quickly running out of words to describe
just how crazy the hype has been in this
latest arc and how much I've been loving
every second of it
the only thing that I'm not loving is
the grueling weekly wait to see what
happens next before we get into it I
just want to let everyone know that we
are organizing a contest where you can
win free shirts from our online store at
anime out Broadcom we have a bunch of
anime inspired designs including Eskin
or praise the Sun meliodas
feel the wrath and even Shaggy
one-shotting Thanos all you have to do
to enter the contest is follow us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
and reply to the linked post saying
which of the shirts you'd like to
receive I will link the Twitter and
Instagram posts directly in the
description and I will also link the
anime opera website so you can go see
all of the shirts that you can choose
from we are going to give away 5 free
shirts on Twitter and 5 free shirts on
Instagram and this contest is actually
brought to you by print if I print if I
is a print on demand platform where
anyone could create and sell custom
printed products they are perfect for
youtubers we actually use them ourselves
so feel free to go check them out their
link is in the description and they are
the ones who will be sending these
shirts to the winners for free so a big
thank you to printf I the winners of the
free shirts will be chosen at random at
the end of February and please make sure
to follow us on Twitter and Instagram so
that we can DM you if you are one of the
winners because we will still need to
get your information and of course if
you decide to actually buy any of these
shirts you will be directly supporting
this channel thank you everyone quick
warning this video will be dealing with
the latest plot developments in the
seven deadly sins manga so if you do not
want any spoilers beyond the anime you
have been warned
please proceed with caution chapter 299
of the manga starts off with zelgius and
miele fighting against each other as
merlin struggles to complete the
incantation that will freeze time inside
the cocoon and stop meliodas from
emerging
after absorbing all 10 commandments
zelgius is really going all out in this
battle showing exceptional resolve and
dedication and almost no regard for his
own well-being zelgius is fighting
desperately to ensure that meliodas will
indeed become the demon king and despite
the fact that smile is keeping him busy
King and the others are still struggling
to keep zelgius from interrupting
Merlin's spell as Hawke observes zelgius
has completely lost himself into
desperation and he is pushing all of his
limits in order to keep his deal with
Mellie Otis and of course as we learn
that deal seems to be that when meliodas
becomes the next demon king he will not
only break the curse placed upon himself
and Elizabeth by the demon king and the
supreme deity but he will also help
zelgius resurrect his lover the vampire
gelda as you would know if you've read
the seven that he sends vampires of
Edinboro side-story
the vampire clan was allied with the
demons during the previous holy war but
they eventually betrayed the demons as a
result zelgius was ordered by the demon
king to kill all the vampires but
because he loves gelda he sealed them
away instead the vampires were
eventually released from the seal some
twelve years ago and they took over the
kingdom of Edinburgh and because of this
the seven deadly sins were dispatched to
fight the vampires gelda herself is an
interesting character because when she
meets meliodas she says that she wants
to die with the man she loves
Zelda's sealed away in the coffin of
eternal darkness she lives just in order
to drain the blood of others which she
needs to do to survive and she tells
meliodas that it would be better if he
just killed her instead however even
though we don't see exactly what happens
it is likely that Mellie oda simply
sealed her away rather than killed her
and since that means that he can break
the seal that he placed on her
Mellie Otis used the prospect of
reuniting zelgius and gelda to convince
zelgius to go along with his plan to
become the new demon king just when it
seems that merlin finally succeeded in
freezing time around the cocoon thereby
making it impossible for meliodas to
emerge zelgius collapses from exhaustion
we really have to give it to zelgius the
way that he can surpass his limits and
go up against Miele
sunshine while also trying to stop
Merlin from completing her spell speaks
to zelgius amazing strength at this
point Hawk King dn Merlin s Kannur
Hendrickson golfer and Elizabeth are
celebrating as they believe that the
holy war is finally over
Merlin is drained after completing the
spell which is noteworthy in itself
since we know that she is supposed to
have infinite magic
everyone wants millie orders to go back
to normal especially since Elizabeth has
only one day left before her curse
activate however it is at this point
that Hawk realizes that the cocoon in
which malleolus was supposed to be
located is actually empty there is a
large tear on the opposite side from
where everyone was standing everyone is
shocked and stunned
not to mention afraid as meliodas the
leader of darkness and the new demon
king makes his appearance zelgius calls
meliodas the demon king and reminds him
to keep his promise and then we see the
face of Melly Otis but here's the
problem
meliodas doesn't look like Melly Otis to
be quite honest he looks almost exactly
like his old wanted poster and he looks
incredibly similar to my hell at first I
thought that maybe meliodas had somehow
possessed Myles body but then I realized
that he doesn't have the same facial
hair on his chin as Miele does and
Millie Otis is also wearing a different
shirt from my elf however it seems clear
that this is indeed meliodas and the
next chapter chapter 300 is even called
the demon king comma Melly Otis so now
we are left with a ton of questions
why did Melly Otis's appearance change
even in flashbacks from 3,000 years ago
he always looked like the Mele Otis we
know now short and childlike the only
exception has been the wanted poster
which was made only 10 years ago when
the seven deadly sins were framed for
murder and in that wanted poster
meliodas also appears to have the same
facial hair on his chin ie the same gold
key as mile slash esta rosa so it is
still a huge mystery why Mele Otis looks
like this now and why his wanted poster
looked the way that it did and of course
the other major questions that we are
now left
wondering is how strong is this new
malleolus and what is he going to do
does he still have control of his reason
and is he going to defeat the demon king
and break the curse while remaining a
good guy who protects his friends or is
he going to be consumed by the darkness
and the power of the commandments and
turn against his own friends and allies
first let's talk about my leotis
appearance and why he now looks like an
adult version of himself we could
speculate a meliodas look the way he did
before because the demon Kings curse
made him stop aging and now that he has
the power to break the curse he has
finally aged as he would have normally
over the course of the past 3,000 years
it is true that zelgius who is meliodas
brother still looks a lot like millie
Otis did in his childlike form but that
could be because zelgius was sealed away
for 3000 years and so he didn't age
because of that maybe in another few
thousand years ljus will look something
like this as well it might be just how
demons of this type a nevertheless even
if this were the case it doesn't explain
why adult meliodas and my L look so much
alike
if the information that we have so far
is correct then Miele is not really
Melly Otis's brother they are not
technically related so why would they
look so much alike I mean I guess it
could all just be a coincidence but if
that's the case then this is a pretty
damn big coincidence personally I think
that there has to be some additional
hidden connection between Melly Otis and
my L something that still hasn't been
revealed another hint as to why meliodas
appearance might have changed came from
the demon king back when we first saw
the two of them speaking in purgatory
the demon king tells meliodas dead by
feeding on his emotions every time le
otis is killed the demon king wants to
make meliodas regain his forgotten
strength and return to the most powerful
demon he once was so perhaps at some
point in the distant past before we met
him and before he fell in love with
Elisabeth meliodas had this adult form
back when he was at his most powerful
and most ruthless however even the
images that we have of Millie orders
back when he was still a commandant
appeared to show him in his childlike
form so there is no clear answer right
now as to why his
appearance has changed so drastically
definitely let me know what you guys
think
why has meliodas appearance changed is
that just because the power of the
commandments allowed him to negate the
effects of the curse and age as he would
have normally aged without the curse or
is this just a different form that
Mellie Otis attains when his full
unfettered demonic power is unleashed
and what is the secret connection
between Mellie Otis and ma hell that
makes them look so much alike let me
know down in the comments I really want
to get a conversation going on all of
these incredibly interesting questions
also what do you think is going to
happen now is meliodas going to continue
to be a good guy and is he now going to
take on the demon king and the supreme
deity along with miele the seven deadly
sins and the others in order to stop the
holy war once and for all or is this new
meliora is going to be consumed by
darkness and become an enemy of my land
the seven deadly sins let me know down
below I have honestly been loving this
arc and I can't wait to see what happens
next
by the way I also can't wait to see this
arc animated if done right it could make
the seven deadly sins anime a battle
shown in classic if you enjoyed this
video you want to see more you can leave
a like to let me know and if you're new
to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
also don't forget to enter the contest
for a chance to win a free shirt just
follow us on Twitter and Instagram at
anime up roar and reply to the linked
post telling us which shirt you would
like to get feel free to check out which
shirts we have available at anime our
Broadcom
all the links are in the description and
a big THANK YOU to printe Phi for making
this contest happen if you happen to be
looking for a company to help you sell
your own merch definitely check them out
link in the description and just a quick
side note all the designs on the website
are exclusive designs created by the pro
manga artist Cuusoo Maddy you can't find
these designs anywhere else because
presumably made them exclusively for us
and he did an amazing job so be sure to
check him out his social media links are
in the description as well as always
thank you all so much for watching and
until next time see our space cowboys
[Music]
you